what if you add David where's my blog I
can't wait two weeks you're not allowed
to have vacation you can't go ahead and
not make a bet amico Oh what is going on
YouTube check it out I've been getting a
lot of messages from y'all and I mean a
lot of messages about this whole and the
cult thing and I'll be honorable to
youtube I had no idea who she was I
don't look that [__] up on Google for
those of you who do not know whoever
coldest ever cold is a girl who is about
14 years old who got caught during
school give it a boy a mouth - ding ding
resuscitation and I was supposed to take
a two-week break because I gave you all
three videos last week but because you
guys have been flooding my message box
with this I'm gonna have to do this i'ma
go get ready for this LG I said let's
get it let's go this is the very damn
reason I do not want to have a child in
this world let alone a daughter I can't
deal with this [__] if I found out that
my daughter had a tank hanging her mouth
show myself I just want to be able to
live my life like a sane human being
because I'd be questioning everything
she does watch she got straight A's
but I never seem to read a book go how
come you run through six jars of combat
some are weak how come she always
scraping up the knees push it on your
place buster
why is it banana her favorite food maybe
good let's talk about let's talk about
this in the same common sense type of
man if you're gonna do the lascivious
act that's why the series I said it
that's a college word college one
affirmation what public while somebody's
recording your ass but they do tell you
that he wasn't gonna post it up and you
actually believed his sorry ass won't
baby love it you don't trust me don't
trust me no no don't be my pleasure
I know positive anyway I go Bulls up
anyway I'm not having a child I'm not
gonna have it if I have a daughter I'm a
dress it up like she's allergic to the
Sun wrap her up like a little ghetto
spring roll and what the hell is up with
this girl
you know he didn't do anything wrong
she's on a steady diet penis for
breakfast and that ain't mom Oh children
are stomping all over the world but
you're crying because a girl suck some
dick and let's not even talk about crazy
person stare right here young lady you
need to back a few inches off the camera
and use a hot tub before you block that
close and why isn't that every single
girl on YouTube has a demon voice was
your last like this one Monica Lewinsky
[__] went down too uh-huh just be by the
Cologne big mother Cologne she just
wanted to get ahead get it ahead get
your [__] together and spend yourself
with holy body a dirty ass satanic
filthy McNasty personally I can say
stuff like Oh back in the day it wasn't
like this people a lot more clean but
you and I we really don't know that
because there wasn't a YouTube to blow
this [__] up or maybe people were just
smart enough not to have that [__]
recorded if this was an asian girl doing
this do you have any idea how fast ur
ass and be [__] back to the homeland oh
my
[Music]